cette affaire a frappé les gens marqué
les gens est ce que les investisseurs
sont mieux protégés qu'il y a quinze
vingt ans stéphane rousseau et
professeur à l'université de montréal
spécialisée en gouvernance et droits des
marchés financiers bonsoir bonsoir
qu'est ce qui a changé monsieur rousseau
fondamentalement dans la protection des
investisseurs depuis la faire notre bout
alors on peut dire qu'il ya plusieurs
mesures qui ont été mises en place pour
dissuader et prévenir les fraudes
financières des mesures d'abord qui
visait justement les fonds
d'investissement notamment un
encadrement des gestionnaires de fonds
comme dans leurs bourreaux pour
permettre à l'autorité des marchés
financiers est vraiment inspecter ses
sephora et s'assurer de leur bon
fonctionnement des mesures pour
renforcer les pouvoirs du tribunal des
marchés financiers pour sanctionner à
nouveau à les contrevenants des mesures
aussi où on a aussi les amendes par voie
législative qui peuvent être décrétés
par les tribunaux en cas d'infraction un
voile et de mesure c'est sont les
mesures de surveillance faites par
l'autorité des marchés financiers ou là
on a mis davantage de ressources
humaines davantage de ressources
matérielles et toute la quincaillerie
informatique qu'on connaît maintenant
pour assurer la meilleure surveillance
des marchés des réseaux sociaux ainsi de
suite est-ce qu'il peut y avoir encore
aujourd'hui un vincent lacroix éric
asselin comme on voit comme on a vu chez
norbourg j'aimerais vous dire non il
mais je pense que ce serait naïf il faut
partir de la prémisse que durera
toujours les acteurs qui vont essayer de
contrevenir aux règles du jeu il faut
partir de cette prime et cela pour
mettre en place un encadrement robuste
et faire en sorte aussi que tous les
intervenants du marché oui les
régulateurs mais aussi les firmes
elle-même les investisseurs soient
vigilants pour 1 contre et ces
contrevenants en 2021 six personnes ont
été condamnées à des peines
d'emprisonnement en vertu des lois
provinciales sur les valeurs mobilières
au canada on parle de peines allant de
cinq mois à 4 ans et demi 6 pen j'ai
raison de penser que c'est pas beaucoup
comme comment il faut interpréter ces
chiffres là oui c'est tout d'abord il
faut dire que ça varie d'une année à
l'autre si on regardait les dernières
années il ya eu des années où on en
avait plus mais plus fondamentalement
faut quand même comprendre que la peine
d'emprisonnement et la peine la plus
radicale comprise décrété et qu'il y a
donc lieu d'être en présence de
comportements qui sont hautement d'evian
qu on souhaite vraiment dissuader aussi
dénoncé de par leur lors des violence
vis-à-vis du public et donc
nécessairement on va se limiter à des
comportements qui sont extrêmes or
l'homme
du reste il faut avoir une
proportionnalité entre la terre et la
contravention mais est ce que dans les
autres types de sanctions est ce qu'il y
a beaucoup de sanctions est ce qu'on
attrape beaucoup de fraudeurs est ce
qu'on les arrête aussi au bon moment en
quelque sorte ouais ben c'est une vaste
question effectivement monsieur fillion
je vous répondrai en disant que les
rapports que rendre les autorités en
valeurs mobilières en chacun et nous
démontre bien qu'il y a un volume
d'activité important un recours est en
décisions en leur faveur on parle
généralement entre 50 et 100 les actions
qui ont intenté à chaque année au niveau
canadien des décisions qui vont varier
en termes de volume trentaine de 50 m
par année sur quel type de méfait oui
alors les méfaits les plus courants
demeure ce qu'on appelle une émission de
titres sans avoir les autorisations
requises sept ans sans prospectus
autrement dit une société qui décide de
lever des capitaux auprès
d'investisseurs sans pour autant avoir
fait la démarche auprès l'autorité des
marchés financiers pour obtenir les
autorisations requises et donc ça c'est
le numéro un avec la fraude qui est
souvent entre mets et les lads des
fausses informations on vous fait la
vente à pression donc ce sont ce genre
de manoeuvres là qui sont les plus
fréquemment année après année recensés
est-ce qu'il est plus dans le cas de
norbourg on parlait de 115 à 130
millions de rats est ce qu'il est plus
facile aujourd'hui de recouvrer les
sommes qu'ils disparaissent bon alors ça
dans les réformes dont je faisais état
tout à l'heure on une info importante
resté garé là notamment au québec et qui
fait en sorte qu' effectivement on peut
recouvrer les hommes de la part des
contrevenants une opération de
restitution un de ces sommes là donc il
fait en sorte qu'on récupère année après
année des sommes pour les redonner le
coz et cher aux investisseurs qui ont
été floués l'année de l'année dernière
on parle d'une quarantaine de millions $
qui ont été recouvrés un si haut niveau
au niveau canadien alors un instrument à
l'arsenal c'est le blocage des fonds
mais ça ça demande qu'on bouge
rapidement pour geler les comptes de
banque et la s'assurer que l'argent ne
s'échappe pas quelles sont les zones de
risque est ce que les investisseurs
aujourd'hui doivent surveiller des
endroits où il peut y avoir un potentiel
plus élevé de fraudes je suis obligé de
répondre tout ce qui s'appelle crypto
actifs de par la complexité de ces
produits là de par l'engouement qui
triment forme par deux forêts quasiment
auprès des investisseurs parce qu'on
nous promet des rendements élevés
potentiellement ça fait en sorte que une
zone pour les fraudeurs assez aisé pour
s'immiscer et dont faire miroiter des
gains rapides se cacher derrière une
complexité pour de toute façon ce n'est
pas réglementée c'est un produit
numérique est donc ainsi appâter les
investisseurs donc le réflexe le bon
réflexe des investisseurs c'est quoi
quand c'est trop beau pour être vrai
c'est trop beau pour être vrai hockey et
donc danger autrement oui exactement
danger apparaît merci beaucoup c'est
très intéressant monsieur rousseau merci
à ces de l'invitation pour voir nos
émissions en entier rendez vous sur la
chaîne ici et redit
oh
[Musique]